[Music]
previously on grit and growth we
explored the stories of two strategic
acquisitions in africa involving
nigerian and ethiopian fintechs and a
kenyan i.t outsourcing company in both
those episodes we got powerful insights
from victor basta ceo of dai magister
in a geography
like the african continent the
multiplier of value multiplication on
your own time of entrepreneurial effort
you cannot get a greater multiplier
anywhere in the world today
victor is an expert in mergers and
acquisitions on the continent and today
we're taking a deeper dive one on one to
discover more about what he's learned
along the way
we discuss the quid pro quo of working
in frontier markets how to attract
potential buyers
how to get your own team on side
and how to maintain value throughout the
due diligence process
[Music]
i'm darius teeter and this is a master
class by gritten growth with stanford
graduate school of business the show
where africa and south asia's intrepid
entrepreneurs share their trials and
triumphs but enough from me let's let
victor introduce himself
so i'm victor bosta i'm the ceo of dii
magister and we're
at the moment probably the most active
advisory firm handling larger rounds and
m a deals for companies in africa and
the middle east growth companies really
focused on tech enabled businesses
i read an interview that you did some
time ago and there was this great quote
in there where you said
you don't see yourself as somebody who
does the deals but someone who helps
people through deals and you consider it
a privilege to be involved in somebody's
transformational life experience
can you say a bit more about that
sure almost everything we do is at a
point where
an enormous amount for a company and a
team is on the line and we get used to
it after a while i've been doing this
almost 30 years but
you know one has to step back a little
bit to realize that pretty much
everything we work on is more than an
affliction point you know more than a
pivot point for a company i've lost
count of the number of life-changing
events i've been a privilege to ever
bring side seat to but more than that
and this is where really the privilege
part comes in you know you're in the
middle of helping create it
so
to be able to create other people's life
changing events
over and over and over again it's the
reason i'm willing to get up and do
conference calls at seven o'clock in the
morning on a saturday after all these
years and it's a reason why we decided
to pivot so much of our work towards
emerging markets which are much harder
to work in but the privilege is even
greater so can you say a little bit more
about that what's happening in the
african emerging market ecosystem in the
in the mergers and acquisition space
that's exciting or interesting or new
for the first time in history you have
a group of companies
that are
starting to transform life on the
continent
in a way that grant money never could
and the process of industrialization
on a continent that has
far less infrastructure
than it needs to have and will
not be fixed for decades the only way to
accelerate
industrialization is through
technology-enabled businesses
of course you need to build rams dams
and rivers and highways but again that
in and of itself is not going to
transform economic life on the continent
the only way to transform economic life
and therefore give ourselves all a
chance
is accelerating the industrialization
successfully of africa and the other
dimension is that for africa to
industrialize successfully
in this day and age isn't the same way
that china did it you know burn coal and
basically scorch the earth we can't
afford to do that
[Music]
industrialization in africa actually
might mean something completely
different which is the you know just
remote distribution of digital services
expansion of network penetration lower
cost of bandwidth lower cost of devices
which enables a whole bunch of things
that never actually need to be brick and
mortar along the way right so
getting back to you know how we bring
that capital into these sectors what
does it look like to do these types of
deals that would bring that kind of
growth capital
in these markets
that money is not available on the
continent for the most part with a very
few exceptions it's not local or
regional or continental money that money
needs to be attracted from abroad
so doing these deals is all about
developing a degree of conviction
from a group of international investors
who could put their money anywhere
do not have to put it into africa
and developing that conviction in what
still is considered a frontier market
means you have to overcome a lot of
initial objections one of the big things
that we see
is that a fair amount of the money
raised is used effectively to quote
reinvent the wheel what i mean by that
is that in europe or the u.s you can
rent infrastructure i mean these days
you can rent aws and rent everything you
can literally get into business tomorrow
and deploy your your product in africa
if you're going to move
food from small holder farmers to
roadside stall holders
you need to have your own trucks you
need to have your own warehouses you
need to have your own tech stack and you
have control of the end-to-end delivery
in the supply chain
that costs a significant amount of money
even in a place like africa and requires
a level of competence that you don't
need to develop in europe or the us and
so what are the quid pro quo's well in
africa
building a business that's 20 30 million
dollars of revenue in a particular
sector particularly in certain
geographies makes you unique
today
in china if you set up a business on a
saturday doing x
chances are if it's even remotely
successful on monday by the following
saturday you'll have 30 competitors
right you can get better margins
you can become profitable more quickly
and even though you're using more
capital to quote reinvent the wheel and
certain elements you're able to make
money out of those assets
in a way that you're not able to
in other markets it's made more
complicated because we haven't seen
exits
repeatedly
and so not many companies have been sold
and one or two have gone public and
that's pretty much it and so people are
taking a leap of faith if i put the
money in and even if the business scales
and it's profitable how do i know i'm
going to get the money out that is a bet
that they need to make still and the bet
they would make in any
emerging geography by the way they'd
have to do that in southeast asia
20 years ago or 15 years ago you don't
now
so
people look at the pattern recognition
that you know that didn't exist in india
20 years ago but look now it exists
[Music]
you describe the complexity of the
operating environment in a lot of these
countries in africa
and
why it might make sense to build a
warehouse because you can't rent
everything does that create an incentive
for
international companies to try to expand
their footprint through acquisition so
that they can find someone who
understands how to navigate all of that
complexity and they don't have to do it
themselves in a sense they're buying the
answer to the complexity problem and
thereby getting at they get access to
200 million people
exactly and
that's the thesis for
getting eventual exits is that there's
going to be a small number of companies
that are now growing quickly that will
graduate to a point where they cover
enough of the continent so they
understand how to be an african platform
business that's number one two they've
solved these kind of problems and keep
them
under the hood if you will right they
know how to do it and it's not a problem
day in and day out their business and
they know how to operate within
different regulatory regimes where
that's appropriate and therefore a large
company doesn't have to do
all that work and take all that time
to try and scale in the continent so
that is the payoff
and that's the bet
that investors are making at the moment
the market is 95
plus fundraising
and a very small proportion m a
ten years from now that will change but
at the moment companies are just in the
process of getting built to a point
where they have the profile you're
talking about but there are 1.2 billion
people in africa and however
little many of them have in terms of
daily income it is rising
so it's only question of time
i agree and i actually think that the
growth curve may be steeper as well all
the trends might be accelerating even
faster than they did for example in
india
what i'm hearing more and more from
these founders is you know in their mind
somewhere in the future they would like
to be acquired through some kind of
strategic partnership for that would
enable them to grow and be part of a
bigger company
so i want you to help me address those
people they've got a startup they've
found secured some venture capital they
see a strong growth path
when
in their mind should they be considering
selling their business what are the
triggers
you don't really choose
your moment at least for the best or
better exits the moment chooses you
and there's a saying about being bought
not sold and the best exits
are companies that are bought not sold
and what i mean is somebody will quote
come along and you know pay strategic
price because
they
have a strategic imperative they want to
expand in this or that area they want to
do a deal to do this and so they find
the best available company to do it and
they oftentimes will pay up for that
the dirty little secret is that being
bought not sold takes an awful lot of
selling beforehand it's just not called
selling
and i've talked about this a few times
in the past
so
what does it mean it means visibility in
all of the different stripes
so one of the things that tech enabled
businesses don't do is spend very much
on what i would call corporate marketing
in africa it's zero
so
you know you're expecting somebody to do
all the work to work out that you're
actually a reasonable size business that
i should be thinking about buying when
my strategic requirements dictate of
course
you can always go do a search for
companies but you know people buy people
they know or people they've heard of and
there's a degree of comfort and
confidence with that the second which is
deeper and more relevant is building
those kind of strategic relationships
commercial awareness etc again
developing relationships with companies
that are likely buyers years ahead of
when they actually might buy because a
you as the ceo of that company have no
idea when they're going to want to buy
and you might or might not have an idea
why
they would want to buy
and the other thing is there will be two
or three or four other companies that
also would make sense to buy at any
point in time and so you are competing
and you better think about that now i.e
well ahead of when you think the exit
window would open because you can't
control
the events most of the best exits we've
worked on are quote surprises
so let's dig into that a little bit i
love the point about visibility
basically visibility equals value
so spending on corporate marketing is
not just an expense it's actually an
investment it should be as an investment
and then
on the business development side try to
make deals with bigger companies so you
can put yourself out there for them to
see you may not be able to see under
their hood but you'd like them to be
able to see what's going on under the
hood in your business right
i'll tell you what we were doing so far
this year right on preparation work we
do a lot of prep work with companies a
year two years plus even before they
would look at doing an exit and so one
of the things we twice actually we've
written year-end press releases
for companies now private company
doesn't have to release any information
but proactively we thought it was a good
idea for both these companies to start
getting in the practice of publishing a
kind of during q1 how did we do last
year
now it's not broadcasting numbers
because aren't that many numbers but
it's broadcasting the messages around
why the company's attractive
so it's almost like you know pitch deck
and the key points that you would want
to land with potential buyers for
example from an african point of view
you know we are going to expand into
ghana and senegal people always look at
the disadvantages
that companies and frontier markets have
so one of the things that a lot of
companies should do is look at the
advantages
so the wall street journal of financial
times
would fall all over themselves to write
an esg driven story about a
purpose-driven business that is scaling
in an incredibly hard market and beating
the odds i mean that story writes itself
and if you were a 20 million dollar sas
business in denmark
no disrespect to denmark nobody would
give you the time of day they don't care
all right you're a 20 million dollar
company doing i don't know supply chain
optimization or whatever in west africa
i mean you will have cnn
as an audience for that you have an
opportunity particularly with the wave
of interest in esg
to land visibility blows left right and
center
in a way that is deeply unfair
i get that and it's not just a
visibility i mean it's another point
i've heard you make before is that
you want to demonstrate your authority
over the topic right so you don't just
write about your product you write about
your industry you write about your
region you write it so because buyers
are interested in expertise and you need
to get on their radar screen
as a viable expert it's all about the
perception of
safety and effectively risk reduction if
i've got a senior team
as expressed by the ceo that really
understands their market and being
authoritative and fault leadership and
all that really is just an expression of
we really understand our market this
goes back to the point you said earlier
which is a buyer will pay the most for a
company that sort of cracked the code
of how to operate so the more
thoughtful you are about market trends
that are really directly relevant to you
put them in a bigger picture
the more that comes across without you
ever having to say hey we know the
market
you're just showing people that you know
it and again there's a huge unfair
advantage going back to my point before
that people companies have in africa and
middle east there's almost no market
research
you can have your own expression
definition of the market
and frankly that if you want a huge body
blow for visibility i mean that is a
nobody in any other part of the world
would ever be able to do their own
primary market research
and get it out there
except in africa
so there's huge opportunities which is a
quick quote for all the friction
[Music]
going back to your earlier point which
is
companies don't really particularly in
these emerging markets they're not
really preparing to sell but they should
be prepared to be bought what things
should i be thinking about as a founder
or ceo
to make my company attractive in the
long run
when somebody starts to look under the
hood
if i'm a large company doing an
acquisition one of the things i want is
a really sturdy and deeper management
team so i'm going to have a premium in
my mind for second line management
below the top two or three people and i
want to know that those people are also
able to scale
and in africa there's as i said a huge
dearth of that cadre
so at an early stage
companies have the opportunity to create
their own kind of talent academy
internally so growing your own but being
able to show a buyer that you've got a
full house
and when you're gone
there's three other people who want your
job
that is incredibly distinctive hard to
do
but
creates a degree of resilience
immediately
so that kind of thing goes an enormous
way
towards converting the buyer because it
takes away the risk
so
to sum it up you may be undervaluing
the human capital assets in your
business that's right
a second thing that companies worry
about
from a buyer point of view is is it an
african platform or not that's different
for different sectors
what is good enough international
expansion but the valuation is 50
higher
if you're an african platform maybe even
100 in some cases versus the same amount
of revenue
that is
regionally locked in one or two markets
only we're actually working on a deal
now which is sort of somewhere between
an acquisition and a merger companies in
two
markets in africa and one of the main
drivers for this is for them to be able
to operate under regulation in both
areas right rather than setting up in a
new market and going through all of that
they want to do an acquisition in order
to be able to show immediately that they
are a pan-african business despite the
regulation and they think that should
increase their price per share almost
overnight pretty significantly and you
know everybody looks for one plus one
equals more than two being able to do
that is one very clear expression of
that
i'd like to pivot to some sort of more
basic practical type advice from you
just to help our listeners understand a
typical m a process and so like what are
the typical steps
in the process
so at its heart it's a deal so the two
elements of it are
obviously finding or engaging a buyer
who's serious and then closing it
they're two very distinct
parts to the process getting a buyer on
the hook
if i could put it that way there are
many ways of going about doing it as i
said if one wants to be bought not sold
and really what that means is you want
the phone to ring
so there are a million things that go
into the phone ringing confidence that
you know you've built relationships with
people you've encouraged a commercial
deal you've informed their own strategic
thinking we've had a client who wrote a
deck we encourage them to send it in
powerpoint not pdf so that the buyer
could lift by the way it was in the
buyer's colors buyer could copy and
paste
a bunch of the graphics for their own
internal presentation of what would make
sense to do a lot of guidance you know
informing etc when a buyer comes to the
table decide to do something
[Music]
so i got the phone call
the first phone call what do i do next
right i've been setting myself up i've
put myself out there i've invested in
corporate marketing i'm a recognized
thought leader i have some important
subcontracts
showing traction i get the call
what do i need to know about this person
who's calling me how do i vet this
potential buyer
well it starts with what do you say what
does a buyer want to hear on the one
hand they want to hear that you're open
but they don't expect to hear any more
than that so the answer usually is you
know something we've been thinking about
we've had on the radar screen our
investors you know have been involved
for x period of time we're open to
talking it's not something that we are
planning to do you want to sometimes
give a little bit of a feel of
exclusivity to the sense of like you
know we're not really going to shop the
company probably we're only going to do
a deal with somebody we know
and actually your timing may not be bad
and what a buyer's really worried about
is that the ceo in particular has
invested so much of his or her time and
blood and guts in the business that they
couldn't they just don't you know
couldn't imagine selling it to somebody
and a lot of deals never got off the
ground because
the buyer has a feeling that it's
they're pushing water uphill
i don't want to lose that point where
the person who gets the call maybe
actually really isn't emotionally ready
to sell their business you always behave
as if you're open even if you're not
emotionally ready
you need to be a grown-up to run a
company you need to be a grown-up on
these phone calls
you know the person calling
has got a strategy behind their call
has got money behind their call
and
you know you also don't know what
they're gonna do
i mean you know they may be doing say
well do i acquire or do i actually
invest to go
in this market there's a lot of things
you don't know
and it would be the height of arrogance
that is not a call i really want to have
if you're the ceo of a business that's
got traction
part of your job description is work out
and exit that's your job
so
it's as simple as do that part of your
job
so what questions should the founder be
asking themselves
in their quiet
dialogue with themselves to understand
whether they are mentally ready
so they're usually their own worst enemy
and especially when you have ecosystems
like in africa where
hardly anybody's ever done an exit you
know the playbook hasn't been written
and you don't know anybody who's done
this so it's not like a valley where you
can call five people and hey you know
how does this all work your first job is
to work out a are they for real
b
is it something that i should spend time
on now this is an example
of where emotion and reaction in a
vacuum because it is a vacuum as an
early ecosystem really can create a
distortion
let's go to that point so i got the call
there's no playbook online for my market
where do i go for help who do i talk to
where do i get what resources do i you
know i can't afford victor basta
who do i call
you're touching a nerve a little bit
because this is really
just where the embryonic nature of an
ecosystem really really bites
right in moments like this if you're the
ceo you have to be cautious with who you
talk to in your entire orbit
ordinarily you'd bring your two or three
direct reports into the know
relatively early on you know and you'd
kind of consult with them and they would
give you their view and you want to make
sure that it's good for employees i
don't want to over
exaggerate this but you do need to be
careful
so that's a really lonely place to be
what's going to end up happening is that
the ceo
he or she needs to fly solo
for probably much longer than they would
do in in a developed market
let's talk a little bit about what
happens as we close this deal i'm the
founder ceo my firm is being acquired
how should i think about my role in this
combined firm what are some of the
different arrangements you've seen
so as a general rule
large buyers
want to legislate
to keep
the ceo much longer than they end up
needing him or her for why is that
it's just
safety de-risk
he or she has led this company and we
want them to lead a business unit and
you know we want everybody in place and
by the way if that person stays we know
that the other 30 people are going to
stay so
we want the ceo to sign a three-year
employment agreement or lock up or
whatever you want to call it right we
want to put their money some of the
money they're going to get frankly at
risk based on them staying in the
business
more than 50 of the time they all
realize after a year or year and a half
businesses moved on we got our arms
around it by the way you're really an
entrepreneur at heart i don't know if
this business unit thing is really for
you they accelerate it and they buy them
out yeah buy them out or terminate early
or you know or maybe change their role
into some other role because sometimes
there's a bigger opportunity for them to
be able to graduate to which is all fine
but far less often than ceos think
is the case
their role
changes materially within a couple of
years of a deal but the legislation at
the time you do the deal is for
everything to be hardwired exactly
the same
as far as the
second line people
normally there is more opportunity
normally for those people than the
company would ever have standalone i
know it sounds a little
counter-intuitive
but when you're looking at strategic
buyers coming into
frontier
geography like africa
very few have got a big footprint that
you need to fold the company into
there's not about like smashing this
with that they're trying to build around
it they're trying to buy africa
in many cases therefore for the second
line person you know who's in their 30s
and wants to be a ceo i mean you're just
going to get another
huge addition to the resources you have
to play with and by the way somebody
who's made a commitment paid a lot of
money to actually go win in africa so
instead of being a startup growth
company whatever you're now
seriously incumbent
now you may not want to do that forever
and want to start your own business but
my god if you can do five seven years of
that and really build it to scale you
can write your ticket anywhere on the
continent with any company
so
that opportunity for second line
managers can really open up
what are some of the common mistakes the
ceos make on the sell side in the m a
process
not rehearsing their full team number
one
there was a deal we worked on a few
years ago
the buyer
came in
to do due diligence a day was on
technical due diligence they went
through the whole day and were perfectly
satisfied the cto turns to the buyer and
says
i don't know why you bothered asking all
these questions you really should have
asked about blank
oops
needless to say technical due diligence
took
weeks and weeks and i think it turned
out i remember right it was an open
source
licensing issue or something like that i
can't remember what it was but you get
the idea so we rehearse and rehearse the
senior team on message so like there are
when you're doing due diligence you know
which is after you've agreed the terms
of the deal and you're now trying to
close it right
the guidance is value can shift
easily
from what you thought you agreed
and people don't realize due diligence
is just checking stuff and then we're
going to close
value shifts in all sorts of ways
[Music]
so victor at the end of the sales
process what does success look like
success is having made only small
compromises
late in the day now it's a
kind of high level thing but
you end up giving stuff away your
maximum point of leverage
when you're selling a business is of the
time you're agreeing the deal right at
that point your leverage begins to wane
away
until a week or two before the deal
closes when you have the least leverage
possible
success is that
you live to fight another day you made
small compromises what we try and do
actually what i try and do is plan ahead
for compromises that seem bigger than
they really are
so one big thing
is around the point we talked about
before which is management retention and
packages right if you can get a buyer a
little more comfortable
change things around a little bit so
that you know that part is really solid
they might forget the 20 million dollars
they want to take off of the price here
and you as the founder
have to understand what's your zone of
agreement what are you actually willing
to give up yeah and also you do you go a
little further even what you do is you
then in the process of due diligence you
are already listening to what the buyer
is saying
and you get to understand what really is
important to the buyer and so if you're
already preparing two or three or four
of these gives late in the process you
want to design them so they're
of most value to the buyer but it's
based on listening to them
what do you wish i'd asked you what
should i have asked you that i haven't
asked
why on earth would anybody
start a growth company in a place like
africa the thing is it's not as simple
as you know making a difference or
having an impact or whatever i think
it's more nuanced than that we all in
our lives look for opportunities where
we can
really get a multiplier on our own time
and the value of our own time
and in a geography
like the african continent the
multiplier of value multiplication on
your own time of entrepreneurial effort
you cannot get a greater multiplier
anywhere in the world today
the reality is that you know there's so
few companies doing it at scale there's
so much to be done it is we talked about
even from a like species point of view
frankly could move the needle this is
not about well i want to feel good or
give back or make the world a better
place nothing against any of that right
but through the sheer effort
that these ceos and senior teams make in
these geographies they get such a higher
multiplier on the value of their time
than anybody ever could anywhere else on
earth
why wouldn't you
thank you victor for guiding our
listeners through some of the best
practices in the acquisition process but
especially for your optimism and
commitment to economic prosperity on the
continent this has been a master class
from grit and growth with stanford
graduate school of business and i'm your
host darius teeter
in an upcoming episode we will hear from
matt abrahams a lecturer at stanford and
the host of the popular podcast think
fast talk smart
matt will guide us through an
interactive workshop to help
entrepreneurs refine their fundraising
pitches i hope you'll join us
if you want to find out more about how
stanford graduate school of business is
partnering with entrepreneurs throughout
africa and south asia through stanford
seed visit us at seed.stanford.edu
podcast if you like this episode don't
forget to hit follow and share it with a
friend written growth is a podcast by
stanford seed lori fuller researched and
developed content for this episode with
additional research by jeff prickett
kendrick gladish is our production
coordinator in our executive producer is
tiffany steves with writing and
production from isabelle pillard and
andrew ganum and sound design and mixing
by alex bennett at lower street media
thanks for joining us we'll see you next
time
[Music]
you